a lot of i see a lot of hate towards
andrew tate on social media um i i
follow him tick tock because i think you
know he's funny to listen to you and
yeah you know but but the funny thing is
the women a lot of the women who
complain about andrew tate are dating
andrew tates
that's that's their list what's the
cognitive disconnect there that they're
dating the guy that they hate on what do
you mean yeah no it's like the the guys
that they're dating are like andrew tate
they're they're a little bit you know
rough they're bad boys they're macho
they're macho they're tough dudes
but then they hate on him but you're
dating the exact same thing so i think
for dudes it's very hard to understand a
woman because on one hand a woman says i
want somebody who takes care of me that
is you know in touch with his feminine
side does this and that and blah blah
but then
it doesn't make their [ __ ] wet at all
but a bad guy that does [ __ ] they you
don't want to have like done to you that
makes their [ __ ] wet yeah
so you know as rolo says shout out to
rologan alpha fox beta bucks right yeah
right it's
it's it's hard it's
female 101 if you know game like what
she says doesn't mean anything watch
what she does exactly watch who she
bangs yeah yeah and that's just humans
in general like like you know we're in
miami right everybody's a [ __ ]
millionaire and [ __ ] or whatever the guy
drives a volkswagen like okay like
something doesn't add up you know you
gotta you gotta interpret their actions
so i think a lot of guys going back to
your point
it's twofold one i think a lot of guys
either a don't have a father that should
be teaching you this stuff confidence is
like i could tell you had a good father
and good family i could just tell by
meeting you thanks bro yeah and so i had
a rough relationship with my dad but he
stayed there the whole time but he was
there he was present yeah we wasn't was
he like whooping your ass yeah but like
like it's not bad
my dad broke my ass like like you know
like 70s it's okay to do this yeah like
nowadays no 70s it's okay to whip your
kids ass yeah but it may be the man who
i am because i was like all right i know
what
i had a very
like i knew what was right and wrong at
a very early age
so that made me very wise and like hip
to the game of like yeah i get it my
dad's got some issues but i'm not gonna
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna improve i'm
not gonna be the guy that's like my dad
hated me he kicked my ass so i'm gonna
be a piece of [ __ ]
can't do that they can't process issues
that way a lot of people like going with
the with the oh i was i was a victim
mentality yeah victim mentality oh 100
victim mentality sucks yeah you don't
get anywhere with that [ __ ] because you
know what you're never going to win the
victim game because there's always going
to be someone that's like
oh you're black i'm [ __ ] oh you're
[ __ ] i'm dying of cancer yeah yeah
oh you like there's always going to be
somebody who's worse set in the bar
lower and lower 100 percent the
opposition olympics
yeah where's that getting you in life
you're worse and worse and worse than
the next person it's just like yeah i
had ben carson on the show today on pbd
podcast if you're not familiar with dr
ben carson megan carson okay he was here
three hours ago
and
you talk about someone that wouldn't
play the victim card this guy grew up
poor illiterate his mom had no money his
mom left him mom illiterate he had a
crazy tamper getting in fights at school
next thing you know he gets his [ __ ]
together he says i'm not gonna be a
victim yeah he becomes a doctor he's
like
becomes the world record forever
disconjoining twins siamese twins or
whatever and he's like i'm not very
i'm not gonna play the victim i'm just
not gonna do it and it's just like
that's his personality 100 so i'm with
him yeah it just it doesn't it doesn't
make sense but going back to the guys
what i'm saying is like i think either
the father is not present
or
he is just like an absentee father he
doesn't teach the sons because like
back in the day
they didn't need men's dating coaches
there was no
space for this because the father there
was no need for andrew tate a hundred
years ago
he's not the hero we want but he's the
hero we deserve so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire size cast
click right here
[Music]